So, let's hear Twinkle Twinkle Little Star. It's amazing, it's sounds, I probably can't play that. And I can explain why as we start chatting about it. This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. A savant is defined as someone who does not have normal intelligence, but possesses unusual mental abilities. My name is Derek Amato, I am 49 years old, I currently live in Virginia. But Derek is an unusual case.
那么，我们来听听《小星星》。这太神奇了，这些声音，我大概弹不出来。等我们开始聊这个时，我可以解释原因。这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。学者症候群患者被定义为智力不正常，但却拥有不寻常精神能力的人。我叫德里克·阿马托，我49岁，目前住在弗吉尼亚州。但德里克是个不同寻常的例子。
He said to have something called a quiet Savan syndrome, it's left him with this incredible ability to compose and play piano. We'll talk about what that means, but let's back up a minute. I grew up a typical kid. I was an extremely aggressive athlete, so that was kind of my thing. I was a baseball football player. You were a jock.
据说他患有一种所谓的“后天性学者症候群”，这让他拥有了非凡的作曲和钢琴演奏能力。我们等下会聊聊这意味着什么，但让我们先倒回几分钟。我是在一个普通家庭长大的孩子。我是一个极具侵略性的运动员，所以这算是我的专长。我曾经是个棒球和橄榄球运动员。你是个体育迷。
I was a jock, yeah. I had musical interest from very early on. My grandmother was a organ player for the church. So, I mean, I was around it. I remember Sunday mornings going, sitting next to her on the bench. Even though I didn't understand what she was doing or how to play the instrument, I loved to sit with her and sing. It was just my comfort zone as a child when I go to church.
我确实是个体育迷，是的。我从很小的时候就对音乐感兴趣。我的祖母是教堂的管风琴手。所以，我的意思是，我一直身处其中。我记得周日早晨去教堂，坐在长椅上挨着她。尽管我不懂她在做什么，也不懂怎么弹奏这个乐器，但我喜欢和她坐在一起唱歌。在我小时候去教堂时，那只是我的舒适区。
I get to sit and watch her play the organ and sing. At his mother's insistence, Derek dabbled in music. He joined the school band, played drums, tinkered around with a guitar, formed a rock band with friends, but he did not take formal lessons or get any musical training. Okay, so that's the setup. What happens to Derek in 2006 is both terrifying and fascinating. He was in South Dakota visiting friends and family. I got together with some friends and we were going to have a little barbecue party at the pool and indoor pool and we were forcing around and
我坐在那里看她弹管风琴并唱歌。在母亲的坚持下，德里克涉足了音乐。他加入学校乐队，打鼓，摆弄吉他，和朋友组建了一支摇滚乐队，但他没有接受过正规课程或任何音乐训练。好的，这就是背景。德里克在2006年遭遇的事情既可怕又迷人。他当时在南达科他州探亲访友。我和一些朋友聚在一起，我们本打算在泳池边开个小型烧烤派对，是一个室内泳池，我们在那里打闹，然后
this young man walked in. He must have been about 14, 12, 14, and he had this little miniature football with him. So of course, we started throwing the football at each other and I thought I could just run on the side of the pool and then dive over the water and catch the football in the air. And the idea was you would catch it and then fall into the pool. Yeah, just catch it in the air and then fall into the water. So I went running on the side in the air. And the idea was you would catch it and then fall into the pool. Yeah, just catch it in the air and then fall into the water.
这个年轻男子走了进来。他大概14岁，12、14岁左右，手里拿着一个小号迷你橄榄球。所以当然，我们开始互相抛橄榄球，我想我可以跑到泳池边，然后潜入水面之上，在空中接住橄榄球。当时的打算是你接住球然后掉进泳池里。是的，就在空中接住然后掉进水里。所以我开始沿着泳池边跑去。在空中。当时的打算是你接住球然后掉进水里。是的，就在空中接住然后掉进水里。
So I went running on the side of the pool. And I remember, I remember running alongside the pool. I remember even diving in to catch the ball. And I knew I was diving towards a shallow end. I was very aware. And I miscalculated the depth, obviously. And I hit the upper left side of my face. And that's all I remember.
所以我开始沿着泳池边跑。我记得，我记得自己正沿着泳池奔跑。我甚至还记得自己为了接球而跳水。我知道自己是朝着浅水区跳的。我非常清楚。很显然，我误判了深度。我的面部左上方撞击了。这就是我记得的全部。
It was like an explosion. And you know, most of us had a head trauma when we were a kid or a hit or a head. It's that sickening feeling you get when it's like, oh no, I know something. I just did something extremely wrong and this isn't right. And I knew I had hurt myself. Diagnosis was a massive concussion. And what was the treatment? Relax, stay quiet, lay in bed for a few days.
那感觉就像一场爆炸。你知道的，我们大多数人在小时候都受过头部创伤或者头部受到撞击。那种感觉太糟糕了，当它发生时你会想：哦不，我知道有些不对劲。我刚刚做了一件极其错误的事，这不对劲。我知道自己受伤了。诊断结果是严重脑震荡。那治疗方法是什么？放松，保持安静，卧床几天。
I spent the night at the hospital, the next morning they sent me home. I went home and I slept for five days, basically. And then you get up and do what? We sit at the table and I said, well, I feel pretty darn good. I know I had an accident and I'm not sure what happened. And I said, well, I'm in a pack and I think I can go back to Denver in a couple days. So I called Rick and I said, why don't you come over and get me, we'll say goodbyes and
我在医院过夜，第二天他们把我送回家。我回家后基本上睡了五天。然后你起来做什么？我们坐在桌旁，我说，嗯，我感觉挺不错的。我知道我出了事故，但我不太确定发生了什么。我说，好吧，我要收拾行李，我想我过几天可以回丹佛了。所以我打电话给里克，我说，你为什么不过来接我，我们道个别，然后
I'll be on my way in a couple of days. And so we went over to the department and we were just hanging out. And he had this tiny keyboard, just this little piece of junk in the corner and it was just on the stand, dusty and not sure if it had ever been played. And I kept staring at it as we were talking
过几天我就要上路了。于是我们去了那个公寓，就在那闲逛。角落里有一个小键盘，只是一件破烂货，放在支架上，落了灰，不知道以前有没有人弹过。我们聊天时，我一直盯着它看。
and we were just sitting talking like just like this. And I kept looking at it and we were talking. And we were just sitting talking like just like this. And I kept looking at it and looking at it curious. It was like not sure why I was drawn to it. And I finally just walked over to it. And I thought, I'll just hit a few of these keys. I turn it on and see what happened. I had no clue. And I sat down.
我们就这样坐着聊天。我一直看着它，我们还在聊天。我们就这样坐着聊天。我一直看着它，好奇地看着它。那种感觉就像是不明白自己为什么会被它吸引。我最后径直走了过去。我想，我只要敲几下这些琴键就行了。我打开它，看看会发生什么。我毫无头绪。我坐了下来。
And my fingers just went crazy. My fingers were like somebody just, I don't know, Rick said the ghost of Beethoven jumped into my body. I don't know how else to explain it. I went crazy and just played and played. And it wasn't like I was just picking away. What did you play? I played, I think it was more of a classical structure to it.
然后我的手指就疯狂地动了起来。我的手指就像是有人，我不知道，里克说贝多芬的灵魂附体了。我不知道该怎么解释。我疯狂地弹奏，不停地弹奏。这不只是在瞎弹。你弹了什么？我弹的，我觉得它更具有古典音乐的结构。
And I sat there and did this for, I don't know, five, six hours without stopping. And we just, I remember looking at him and there was tears rolling out his face. I mean he's a Christian kid, he's a pretty emotional guy, he's a sweet, sweet man. And he just, you know, he didn't know what to think as because I mean I'm known him since we were kids and he'd never seen me play a piano so he's like, what's going on? I'm not sure what's going on. I didn't want to stop playing because I was like, well, what if I stop
我就坐在那里弹了五个、六个小时没有停下来。我记得看着他，眼泪顺着他的脸滑落。我的意思是，他是个基督徒男孩，他是个感情挺丰富的人，他是个非常非常温柔的人。他只是，你知道的，他不知道该作何感想，因为自从我们小时候起我就认识他了，他从没见过我弹钢琴，所以他在想，这到底是怎么回事？我也不太确定是怎么回事。我不想停下来，因为我在想，好吧，如果我停下来了
and then this doesn't happen tomorrow morning? I mean, this is kind of cool. I don't, I mean, it doesn't happen every day. You just sit out and start playing a piano. So I think this is kind of different. Let's just stay here for a while. It must have been two o'clock in the morning and I was exhausted.
明天早上这就不灵了呢？我的意思是，这挺酷的。我并不是说，这种事不会每天都发生。你只是坐在那开始弹钢琴。所以我觉得这挺不一样的。我们就在这待一会儿吧。当时一定已经是凌晨两点了，我筋疲力尽。
My brain was flying, still racing. And so he took me back to my mother's house. We had a call the day. I was, you know, beat up and I went to bed. And the next morning I woke up and I was paranoid. I was nervous. I was scared. I was like, how am I going to tell my mother?
我的大脑还在飞速运转，依然在狂奔。于是他把我送回了我母亲家。那天我们通了电话。我，你知道的，浑身酸痛，然后上床睡觉了。第二天早上我醒来时，我感到偏执。我很紧张。我很害怕。我在想：我要怎么告诉我母亲？
The person that knows me best on this planet. I just hit my head and I'm a little whacked out. How am I going to tell her that I just discovered that I know how to play the piano fairly well to a person that's known me my entire life, 40 years? So I said, well, I don't know any other way than to take her to a music store. So I said, we had a cup of coffee and I said, it's front of the music store real quick. And she said, what do you want to buy? And I said, nothing.
这个星球上最了解我的人。我刚刚撞了脑袋，有点精神失常。我要怎么对一个认识了我整整40年、伴随了我一生的人说，我刚刚发现自己挺会弹钢琴的呢？所以我想，除了带她去乐器行，我别无他法。于是我说，我们喝了杯咖啡，然后我说，去乐器行门口一下。她说，你想买什么？我说，什么都不买。
I said, I just want to show you something real fast. I went teller. We get to the music store. We walk in, the salesman says, I don't know, like, you know, he can help you. He wants to sell me something. And I said, if you show me how to get this piano, this digital piano on, that's all I need. And then give me just 10 minutes.
我说，我只是想让你快点看个东西。我去了售货员那里。我们到了乐器行。我们走进去，销售人员说，我不知道，好像是说他能帮上忙。他想向我推销东西。我说，如果你教我怎么打开这台钢琴，这台数码钢琴，这就够了。然后只要给我10分钟。
So he turns it on, shows me how to turn the darn thing on. I tell my mother to sit down next to me. What did you play? I don't quite remember what I played that time, but I was doing more of a, I wanted to sing to her for some reason because it was such an emotional thing. And I was going into like, And I just started to kind of chord this and she was looking at me like, whoa, when did this transpire? I mean, she had all kinds of questions right away.
于是他打开了它，教我怎么打开那个该死的东西。我叫母亲在我旁边坐下。你弹了什么？我不太记得那次我弹了什么了，但我当时做的更多的是，不知为什么我想要为她唱歌，因为那是一种非常情绪化的体验。我开始弹奏像，然后我开始弹奏和弦，她看着我，眼神仿佛在说：哇，这是什么时候发生的？我的意思是，她立刻产生了一大堆问题。
And then I just kind of went nuts and started going crazy just to show her, look at this, look at this. And she started, she really did say much. It was a very quiet drive home. As you're telling me this, Derek, I almost have the feeling that you are pulling my leg right now because it seems this is not possible. This is just simply not. It could not have happened. You know, well, if I would have had my way, I'm not sure if I would have ended up a piano player. I kind of wanted to be a baseball player. I work in the fighting business. So I don't know. I and you know what, I kind of wanted to be a baseball player, or work in the fighting business.
然后我有点像疯了一样开始狂弹，只是为了向她展示，看这个，看这个。她开始，她其实没说太多话。回家的车程非常安静。德里克，你跟我说这些的时候，我几乎觉得你是在跟我开玩笑，因为这似乎是不可能的。这简直不可能。这不可能发生。你知道的，好吧，如果由我做主的话，我不确定自己最终会不会成为一个钢琴演奏者。我其实更想成为一名棒球运动员。我在格斗行业工作。所以我不确定。而且你知道吗，我其实挺想成为一名棒球运动员，或者在格斗行业工作。
I don't know. And you know what, I invite skepticism because I think when something so beautiful and profound happens, we have to question. At what stage did you stop questioning that you had a scale? I'm assuming that you were skeptical as well. I mean, you told me that when you went home the first night, you were afraid that it was going to be a one-day skill and it was going to be gone by the next morning. At what point did you stop questioning it and say, this is actually a new skill that I have? You know, I think you kind of grow into that, getting comfortable with accepting what's transpired in your life. I definitely didn't want it to go away. In the first year or two, it was a little, you know, like I would wake up thinking, I need to get to a piano, I need to make
我不知道。而且你知道吗，我欢迎质疑，因为我认为当如此美丽而深奥的事情发生时，我们必须质疑。你在哪个阶段停止质疑自己拥有这种天赋的？我假设你一开始也是持怀疑态度的。我的意思是，你告诉我，第一天晚上回家时，你害怕这只是一项一天的技能，第二天早上就会消失。你在哪个阶段停止了质疑，并说：这其实是我的一项新技能？你知道的，我想你会慢慢适应这种状态，开始坦然接受生活中发生的一切。我绝对不希望它消失。在最初的一两年里，情况有点，你知道的，比如我醒来时会想，我需要去一架钢琴前，我需要确信
sure it's still here. And as time went on, I started to understand that, well, the doctors tell me it can go away as fast as it came. And acquired musical savants syndrome, that means you've acquired and acquired musical savants syndrome. That means you've acquired a gift. And I got to that point where I just accepted the fact that I'm going to enjoy every second of this. Because if I wake up tomorrow and it's gone, I want to be able to say that I did the best I could to display it to a society looking in at my life and say,
它还在。随着时间的推移，我开始明白，医生告诉我它可能会像来时一样快地消失。而后天性学者症候群，这意味着你获得了一项天赋。我到了那个地步，我只是接受了这样一个事实：我要享受其中的每一秒。因为如果我明天醒来它消失了，我希望能够说，我尽了最大努力向这个审视我生活社会的展示了它，并说：
I've been inspired by this or the human potential is amazing or the brain is just a magnificent organ that we don't know anything about. And I think it became that comfort knowing that I'm going to enjoy it every single second. And if it stays beautiful, if it goes away then I guess I'll go get a job. Have you spoken to neurologists who are skeptical about what's happening to you? I think they're all skeptical the moment they walk in the door. I mean, I feel skeptical. I'm sorry.
我为此受到鼓舞，或者人类的潜力是惊人的，或者大脑只是一个我们一无所知的神奇器官。我认为它变成了一种安慰，让我知道我要享受它的每一分每一秒。如果它一直这么美妙那就太好了，如果它消失了，我想我就去找个工作。你有没有和对你身上发生的事情持怀疑态度的神经学家谈过？我想他们一进门时都是怀疑的。我的意思是，我觉得自己也很怀疑。抱歉。
I know that you're a nice guy. You seem like a trustworthy person. Right. Right. I expect you to be. But I have the feeling that you're just, this is just one big giant prank. Well, that's because I'm still, I'm articulate and I still have most of my marbles. So I can display the story in a different way than let's say the guy that hit his head and woke up a piano player, but he's not all here. If I was you to play Twinkle Twinkle Little Star for me, could you try that?
我知道你是个好人。你看起来是个值得信赖的人。对。对。我本该这么觉得。但我有种感觉，你只是，这只是一个巨大的恶作剧。好吧，那是因为我还很健谈，而且我的理智大部分都还在。所以我可以以一种不同的方式展现这个故事，比如换作那个撞了头部醒来后成了一个钢琴演奏者、但神志却不太清醒的人。如果我让你为我弹奏《小星星》，你能试试吗？
I don't think I can play it. I tried to do happy birthday for a person the other day and I couldn't figure it out. No, answers no. It's taught with C. Is that this one right here? Oh, wait. Where was that first note then? Wait. Where it, oh. Oh, so it's all up and down. Gosh, darn it.
我觉得我弹不了。前几天我尝试为一个人弹《生日快乐》，我都弹不出来。不，答案是否定的。它是以C调开始的。是这个音吗？哦，等等。那第一个音在哪里呢？等等。它在哪，哦。哦，所以它是上下起伏的。天哪，该死。
I can see it now. I mean, that's kind of the there. Thank you. Thanks for the first note though. But it's sort of an interesting thing, isn't it, which is like, you don't go up, you don't see someone who says, I can throw a fastball at, I don't know,
我现在能看出来了。我的意思是，这就有点像那个。谢谢。不过谢谢你提醒第一个音。但这其实是一件很有趣的事情，不是吗？就像，你不会看到有人说，我能投出，我不知道，
140 miles an hour, but I don't know how to reach out and shake your hand. And to me, your displaying musical ability at one end of the spectrum, whereas playing Twinkle Twinkle Little Star, I can do that. And you find it hard. And I find it just really difficult to understand how you can be so good at the extreme end without knowing the basics. I'm right there with you. I'm on your side. I am fascinating with that too. Does it disturb you? Does it worry you that you have this ability? No, I mean, I'm a Christian kid, so I think I think this is what God wants me.
时速140英里的快速球，但我不知道怎么伸手跟你握手。对听众来说，你在光谱的一端展现出音乐才华，而弹奏《小星星》这种事我能做到，你却觉得很难。而我真的很难理解，为什么你既不懂基础知识，却又能在这个极端的领域做得这么好。我和你是一伙的。我站在你这边。我也对此着迷。这会困扰你吗？你拥有这种能力会让你担心吗？不，我的意思是，我是个基督教徒，所以我想，我想这是上帝希望我做到的。
I think this has already been penned out my story. I mean, I have to live with this every day, so if I sit and beat my own mind up about, is this nature versus nurture and nature and all this nonsense? But I mean, I've talked to the best doctors, the smart doctors, and his planet. And they all got a different little input, and they all got something different to say about it. Most all of them are skeptic when I walk in, and most all of them when I walk out are right here with me.
我想我的故事早已写好了。我的意思是，我每天都必须带着这个生活，所以如果我坐在这里折磨自己的大脑，去想这是先天与后天的较量，还是自然之类的废话？但我的意思是，我跟这个星球上最好的、最聪明的医生谈过。他们每个人都有不同的见解，对这件事都有不同的说法。我进门时他们绝大多数都持怀疑态度，而当我出门时，绝大多数都和我站在了一边。
Have any of them suggested treatments? Yes, yes, the Dr. Reeves at the Mayo Clinic, when I was filming with the Discovery Channel, he was fascinated with this as well, and he said, the best way to fair him to explain it is like a roller coaster. If you get on a roller coaster that doesn't stop sooner or later it's going to get tiring. So maybe we suggest slowing down the stimulant, the overstimulated brain, you're firing these neurons at a pace that's unheard of. So let's try some seizure medication to shut those down, right? I don't know understand how it works,
他们有没有建议过什么治疗方法？有，有的，梅奥诊所的里夫斯博士，当我与探索频道合作拍摄时，他也对这一点着迷，他说，用过山车来解释它是最恰当的比方。如果你坐上一辆不停下来的过山车，迟早你会感到疲惫。所以也许我们建议放慢刺激，针对过度刺激的大脑，你以一种前所未有的速度激发这些神经元。所以让我们尝试一些抗癫痫药物来关闭它们，对吧？我不知道它是如何运作的，
but I do know it slows down the firing of the neurons. Oh, why would I wanna take synthetic drugs and mask something possibly that I'm enjoying to the point where I don't want it to slow down and go away. I'll take the hyperness and the ADHD and OCD and all that garbage that comes with this maybe. What if it has a consequence where you are burning your brain at a level that is not healthy for you? I mean, so for example, let's...
但我确实知道它能减缓神经元的激发。哦，我为什么要服用合成药物来掩盖某些可能正让我享受、甚至我不想让它减缓并消失的东西呢？我宁愿接受这种亢奋、多动症、强迫症以及随之而来的所有垃圾。如果它带来的后果是你在以一种对你不健康的高度燃烧大脑呢？我的意思是，比如，让我们……
Then I guess I go down on fire, baby. And that's how the story ends and I'm good with that. You're still the guy who would die for the swoop football of the swimming pool. Of course, Derek Amato isn't the only person with a quads of Ancindro. Others have experienced the profound changes that come with this condition. They are so motivated, they are in love with what they're doing. It's almost like an extension of who they are. Also, I'm going to challenge Derek to play the studio wall.
那我想我会燃烧着毁灭吧，宝贝。故事就是这样结束的，我对此很满意。你依然是那个愿意为了游泳池里的橄榄球而拼命的家伙。当然，德里克·阿马托并不是唯一一个患有后天性学者症候群的人。其他人也经历过这种疾病带来的深刻变化。他们动力十足，热爱自己正在做的事情。这几乎就像是他们自己的一部分延伸。另外，我要挑战德里克去弹奏工作室的墙壁。
I see on this wall, I see these squares. Some of them have different depths, so the full squares almost feel like a whole note to me. Keep listening, it'll make more sense soon. I'm Shankar Vedantam and you're listening to Hidden Brain from NPR. This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. This week on the show, we're looking at the specific moments people lose something big and how that change can point them in new directions. Before the break, Derek Amato told us a story of how he became a musician after a head
我看到这面墙上，我看到了这些方块。其中一些有不同的深度，所以满格的方块对我来说几乎就像是一个全音符。继续听下去，很快就会更容易理解。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆，您收听的是NPR的《隐藏的大脑》。这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。本周节目中，我们将关注人们失去重要事物的特定时刻，以及这种改变如何为他们指明新的方向。在休息前，德里克·阿马托给我们讲述了他如何在头部受伤后成为一名音乐家的故事。
injury. Before the accident, he couldn't play the piano. But after, his musical talent was just undeniable. If this is the first time you're hearing our show, I have a confession to make. I'm a card-carrying rationalist. When surprising things happen, I don't call them miracles. I look for explanations. Derrick's very charming, his story is amazing, but I found myself asking over and over how something like this could happen. That's when I came by a couple of researchers who've spent years studying people
在事故发生前，他不会弹钢琴。但在那之后，他的音乐才华是不容否认的。如果这是您第一次收听我们的节目，我得坦白一件事。我是一个货真价实的理性主义者。当令人惊奇的事情发生时，我不会称它们为奇迹。我在寻找解释。德里克非常迷人，他的故事令人惊叹，但我发现自己一次又一次地在问，这样的事情怎么可能会发生。就在那时，我遇到了一对研究人员，他们花了多年时间研究那些
who've suddenly acquired savant-like gifts. Darrell Treffert is a psychiatrist in Wisconsin. He studied Derek. And I must say that in his case, I'm, you know, was a startled as you about the fact that he went to the piano and knew where to place his fingers and so forth. The reason that I'm inclined to accept that is because I've seen that in some of these other cases, although probably not quite as abrupt as he but, and to me at least, that having seen a lot of sub-hands when I see some of these
突然获得类似学者天赋的人。达雷尔·特雷弗特是威斯康星州的一名精神病学家。他研究过德里克。我必须说，就他的案子而言，你知道的，我和你一样惊讶，惊讶于他走到钢琴前就知道该把手指放在哪里等等。我倾向于接受这一点的原因是因为我在其他一些案例中也见过这种情况，尽管可能没有他那么突然，但对我来说，至少在见过很多学者之后，当我看到其中一些
acquired sub-hands cases, it is really quite jarring. I don't know if you remember what Derek said about his injury. He leaped across the swimming pool for the football, and when he came down hard, he heard what sounded like an explosion. And I miscalculated the depth, obviously, and I hit the upper left side of my face. The left side of his face, that's an important clue. In general, in Savon Syndrome itself, whether congenital or acquired,
后天性学者案例时，确实相当震撼。我不知道你是否还记得德里克关于他受伤的描述。他为了接橄榄球跃过游泳池，当他重重落下时，他听到了听起来像爆炸的声音。很显然，我误判了深度，我的面部左上方撞击了。他脸部的左侧，这是一个重要线索。总的来说，在学者症候群本身中，无论是先天性的还是后天获得的，
there tends to be a more left brain injury with right brain compensation and the right brain areas or ability that seem to emerge have to do with art music and mathematics, actually. Art, music, and math, all skills that involve pattern recognition. At the University of Pennsylvania, cognitive psychologist Scott Barry Kaufman said, think about it. These are the skills you might imagine are built into the architecture of the brain. In other words, we might come hardwired for certain kinds of activities. This
往往左脑受伤较多，伴随右脑代偿，而似乎显现出来的右脑区域或能力实际上与艺术、音乐和数学有关。艺术、音乐和数学，所有这些技能都涉及模式识别。宾夕法尼亚大学的认知心理学家斯科特·巴里·考夫曼说，想想看。这些技能你可以想象是内置在大脑结构中的。换句话说，我们可能对某些类型的活动天生就有硬编码的连接。这
is the insight that helped me see that Derek might not be pulling a prank. Most of us, in fact, effortlessly learn things. Just like Derek says he never took classes to learn piano, you probably didn't take formal lessons to learn your first language. The truth is that a lot of things we learn in life were not done deliberately. When we were very young and the teachers of two and four, we learned a huge amount of new words and learned the grammatical structure of our language automatically without we didn't sit down when we were two years old and say right I'm gonna learn all the grammatical syntax and what it all means and so we have these structures that help us learn
就是这个见解帮助我认识到德里克可能不是在开玩笑。事实上，我们大多数人都在毫不费力地学习事物。就像德里克说他从未上过学习钢琴的课一样，你大概也没有参加过正规课程来学习你的第一门语言。事实是，我们在生活中学到的很多东西都不是刻意去做的。当我们很小的时候，大约两四岁左右，我们自动地学了大量的新词，并学会了语言的语法结构，我们并没有在两岁大时坐下来，说“好啦，我要学习所有的语法句法以及它代表的全部意义”，所以我们拥有这些能帮我们学习的结构。
If you look at it this way most people have skills that might seem Savant like to a visitor from another planet we learn these skills effortlessly In fact, it doesn't even feel like learning it feels like fun What makes Savants unique in other words is not that their brains do amazing things. All brains do amazing things. What's different is that they're demonstrating effortless learning in domains that usually call for sustained effort. Now, I'm not going to tell you you should go out and bang your head against the floor of a swimming pool to learn to play the piano. The vast majority of concussions don't produce an inner genius, they have terrible outcomes.
如果你从这个角度来看，大多数人拥有的技能对于来自另一个星球的访客来说，可能看起来就像学者一样。我们毫不费力地掌握了这些技能。事实上，它甚至不觉得像是在学习，它感觉就像是在玩耍。换句话说，学者的独特之处不在于他们的大脑能做出惊人的事情。所有的大脑都能做出惊人的事情。不同之处在于，他们在通常需要持续努力的领域展现出了毫不费力的学习能力。现在，我不是在告诉你，你应该去拿头撞游泳池底来学弹钢琴。绝大多数脑震荡都不会催生出一个内心的天才，它们会带来可怕的后果。
But Derek's story does suggest, even to this card carrying rationalist, that we have worlds within us, gifts, that we do not realize that we possess. When I look at these savants, what I see at the core that I think is offers a lot of inspiration to humanity, is that they are so motivated, they are in love with what they're doing. It's almost like an extension of who they are. To me, that offers a lot of hope or inspires me that perhaps all of us can find that vehicle that really allows us to sing. As Derek was playing the piano in NPR studio one, I noticed there was a wall behind him. It had soundproofing, hollow wooden cubes, each of a different depth.
但德里克的故事确实表明，即使对于我这个坚定的理性主义者来说，我们的内心也拥有着我们自己都没有意识到的广阔世界和天赋。当我看着这些学者时，我看到的核心部分——我认为它为人类提供了很多启发——是他们动力十足，他们热爱自己所做的事情。这几乎就像是他们自己的一部分延伸。对我来说，这带来了许多希望，或者启发了我：也许我们所有人都能找到那个真正能让我们放声歌唱的载体。当德里克在NPR第一工作室弹奏钢琴时，我注意到他身后有一面墙。它有隔音效果，是空心的木质方块，每个方块的深度都不同。
Derek had told me that when he plays, he sees squares floating by him. So I asked him to turn around, look at the wall, and tell me what he saw. I see on this wall, I see these squares. Some of them have different depths. So the full squares almost feel like a whole note to me. I ask Derek to play the wall for me. I see low notes because of all the depth. You see the dark ones that are filled in all the way?
德里克曾告诉我，当他弹奏时，他看到方块从他身边漂过。所以我请他转过身，看着墙壁，告诉他看到了什么。我看到这面墙上，我看到了这些方块。其中一些有不同的深度。所以满格的方块对我来说几乎就像是一个全音符。我请德里克为我弹奏这面墙。因为所有的深度，我看到了低音。你看到那些被完全填满的暗色方块了吗？
They stand out, so I see low notes like. Now I'm in the middle boxes. See where I'm at now in those middle boxes, so those are... And that's a whole different... Now we're getting into a whole different thing. Now I'm getting excited. You got any more walls with the look at it. So you were just playing the wall?
它们很显眼，所以我看到了这样的低音。现在我来到了中间的方格。看我现在在那些中间方格中的位置，所以这些是……这是一个完全不同的……现在我们进入了一个完全不同的东西。现在我开始兴奋了。你还有别的墙可以看吗？所以你刚才是在弹奏这面墙？
That's what you were playing with. I was playing the music on the wall. So I started here. Okay, so imagine that's the music bar. So I played playing what I was. So I started here. Okay, so imagine that's the music bar. Yeah. So I played the top one. I'll do it again.
这就是你刚才在弹的东西。我是在弹奏墙上的音乐。所以我从这里开始。好的，所以想象那是音乐小节。所以我弹奏了……我开始从这里。好的，想象那是音乐小节。是的。所以我弹了上面那个。我再做一次。
I'll do it precisely exactly like I saw it. And then it changes to this bar we've moved down now and now we're going to move down to the next bar of music and I see. And we'll go back up to the top. And then we can make a jazz. And that's, I mean, it just goes on and on and on and on. And these walls could be dangerous because I wouldn't want to sleep at all. If I had walls like this in my house. Are you telling me that you have never played the piece of music you just played for me
我会完全准确地按照我看到的来弹。然后它变了，变成了这个小节，我们现在往下移了，现在我们要移到下一个音乐小节，我看到。然后我们再回到顶部。然后我们可以即兴来一段。我的意思是，这会一直持续下去，没完没了。这些墙可能会很危险，因为我根本不想睡觉了。如果我家里有这样的墙。你是说你从来没有弹过你刚才为我弹的那段音乐
in your life before? No. And this third row might even be a whole different composition. That's what I'm saying. The depths of those blocks, those middle rows and those circles in the middle. That's what these are to me. That's what... middle rows and those circles in the middle. That's what these are to me. That's what... Those are rolling patterns to me. And then those chunky ones on the top. That's where I see that. And it just changes like that suddenly. And then I moved out of the next one and it's a whole different flow.
在你的人生中？没有。第三排甚至可能是完全不同的作品。这就是我所说的。那些方块的深度，那些中间排和中间的圆圈。对我来说，这些就是这些。那就是……中间排和中间的圆圈。对我来说，这些就是这些。那就是……这些对我来说是滚动的图案。然后上面那些厚实的方块。那就是我看到它的地方。然后它就这样突然改变了。然后我移到了下一个，完全是另一种不同的流动。
That's Derek Amato, playing the wall in NPR Studio One. This episode of Hidden Brain was produced by Cara McGurk-Allison with help from Neil T. Vult. Our staff includes Maggie Penman, Jenny Schmitt, Chris Banderav and Renee Clarre. Our new supervising producer is Tara Boyle. Find more hidden brain on Facebook, Twitter and Instagram and listen for my stories on your local public radio station. If you like this episode, give us a review. It helps. I'm Shankar Vedathan and this is NPR.
那是德里克·阿马托在NPR第一工作室弹奏墙壁。本期《隐藏的大脑》由卡拉·麦克格克-埃利森制作，尼尔·T·伏尔特提供了帮助。我们的员工包括玛吉·彭曼、珍妮·施密特、克里斯·班德拉夫和蕾妮·克拉雷。我们的新监制是塔拉·博伊尔。请在Facebook、Twitter和Instagram上关注更多《隐藏的大脑》，并在您当地的公共广播电台上收听我的故事。如果您喜欢这期节目，请给我们写个评价。这很有帮助。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆，这里是NPR。
and this is NPR. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
这里是NPR。该剧集尚无评论。点击转录文本中的任何句子即可发表评论。